the mythical golem was imagined as an
artificial intelligence designed to
serve and protect the myth is now a
reality
[Music]
this self-driving vehicle crossed the
entire United States without a human
touching the wheel
the computer was creative it outsmarted
me every step of the way
entrepreneur visionary genius JCL its
planning to change the world
this is our first deployment of lethal
drones JCL is a billionaire entrepreneur
and tech genius here's the brains power
and desire to do great things for
Humanity and he legitimately believes
that he can do so
Jase why not to create scale technology
established in 1997 in San Francisco
scale tech makes software and hardware
for civilian use but has also found
success in developing weaponry and
state-of-the-art technology for the
government to be used in the military
sector but JC's mission has stayed true
he wants to make the world a better
place
hi my name is Jace Cal I'm the founder
of scale technology ever since its
creation scale tech has been harnessing
innovations in industrial science to
serve the common good
we at scale tech dare to dream big and
strive fearlessly to achieve those
dreams every day we work tirelessly to
enhance technology and our quest to
create a better world
today the entire team at scale Tech is
proud to present a new range of drones
for public and personal use agriculture
transportation security maintenance our
families of autonomous machines are
designed to free mankind from its
tedious limitations making day-to-day
life more peaceful and accommodating to
a meaningful existence throughout the
world the scale farmer for example is a
revolutionary drone capable of seating
and toiling difficult soils providing
food for the most remote locations on
the planet the scale pollinator can be
used for flower pollination as a
substitute to bees ensuring our
biosphere develops and thrives for
decades to come the scale doctor is
specialized in emergency intervention
delivering medical support in the most
trying scenarios these are but a sample
of the new series of drones were
launching new models upgrades and
specialization kits will be released in
the months and years to come such as the
scale handy
and the city chairman a drone capable
patrolling our streets to keep them safe
and secure I hope you're as excited as
we are we are working without boundaries
to bring to life the world of tomorrow
scale technology a better future today
[Music]
in 2011
je suis not to purchase an island in the
South Pacific Aurora this was to become
the new scale technology headquarters
the whole island was transformed into a
haven for the technological advancement
of mankind in 2016 it was complete in
2019 scale technology started inviting
as 10,000 employees and their families
to live on it
during operation oracle were introduced
to fellow ghost cult Dean Walker Walker
is fourth-generation army he graduated
top of his class
Walker was groomed for a Strategic
Command career and field operations
Delta Force wanted him after he broke
the record for the land navigation test
and he was recruited by the ghosts he
was assigned for borderline retaliation
operations against dirty targets under
the US or American allied protection
after being sent in by CIA contact Karen
Bowman to extract missing scale tech
engineer the ghost came across Walker
who seems to be working under his own
agenda the scale tech engineer has
knowledge of sensitive US industrial
secrets that need to be protected so
they don't fall into the hands of uni
dead
however walker's found out that the
engineer was the one who designed an
advanced surveillance drone for uni dead
the stone was then weaponized and used
to kill two of Walker's team Walker is
out for revenge
Walker also blames Bowman for allowing
the engineer to a continuous
relationship with the Union ed as is a
protected informant of the CIA
nomads [ __ ] Walker the hell are you
doing here
Bowman didn't say to expect you cuz that
tough little handler of ours got no idea
I'm here what you sightseeing hunting
trip huh what's the game high level
skilled tech engineer Daniel Rodriguez
hurry on home see Danny here he's got
access to company technology that the
government does not want shared but he's
been spending a lot of time and Bolivia
probably not out here soaking up that
culture huh he's been selling secrets to
unidad so he and I we're about to have a
little chat our mission from Bowman
was to rescue him from unidad I could
blow sunshine up your ass all day but
I'll spare you
Bowman she's my real target they know
exactly what he's been knowing she's
been protecting a little [ __ ] what's he
do for them inform it inside you two
dead these must be some pretty serious
secrets for you to go off-script must be
[ __ ]
get him up okay uh khyati you want to
lift through this you follow me and do
as I say
YouTube doesn't make it out
the engineer is rescued and sent back to
rendezvous with Berman Walker wants to
investigate Berman's meeting but
discovers the engineers sold Berman out
to uni dead after interrogation Walker
kills all the ghosts and Walker managed
to rescue Berman and take her back to a
safe house Walker is a number of
accusations that expects her to answer
all right enough with the games what's
this all about [ __ ] about it's about you
helping her steal information from the
government giving it to unidad I didn't
steal anything I was helping a spy an
enemy spy now hold on my orders were to
protect him for the success of multiple
US interests in Bolivia and the Bolivian
people spoken like a true traitor
whatever happened to loyalty to country
you should have killed that engineer the
second you knew he turned if you could
protect a man like that what's to keep
you from selling information yourself
[ __ ] you I had orders and I was
following them orders orders you orders
got my men killed
they ain't an enemy I'll take your
orders and shove up your ass Walker now
that she gets dirty we all get paid to
root around of the scum now we come out
of that muck as clean as we can
listen know what side I'm on
look I'm sorry for the loss of your men
really now I might strut around like I'm
the [ __ ] of the walk but I don't call
the shots
I follow orders [ __ ]
you had command on the ground you call
the shots every time you obey an order
listen you've been out there this is an
impossible situation at least Bowman
gives a [ __ ] you trust that spook you
gotta trust somebody Walker okay not
used to trust you for now I'll trust her
you keep your nose clean moment you owe
me for the lives of two of my men you
straight what I order this Saturday I'll
come and I will collect on that dead
this is where operation Oracle ends but
sometime after this event something
heavens something that would take coldy
Walker and heaven would draw his
allegiance to the ghosts in the CIA
four years later in 2023 skel technology
has come under public scrutiny after
being instigated in a political
assassination the United States
government decides to investigate
further only to find it at Aurora has
cut itself off on top of this the island
of hurrah seems to have been taken
hostage by a group of former ghost
operators known as the wolf's and this
group is led by Col Dee Walker Walker
has gone rogue
and he's using scale tech drones to hunt
down those who have used scale
technologies products and have them
murdered he's also hired a private
military contractor seem to know to help
secure the island using the drones the
Wolves managed to take down the four
helicopters that was sent to Aurora to
investigate causing them to crash onto
the island the majority of the 32 ghosts
sent were killed
[Music]
so in those four years what happened
did Walker find more evidence that the
government is supporting unis dead or is
he simply Grant's sick of seeing skeltox
advanced technology falling into the
wrong hands
although portrayed in a negative light
fighting against the United States
Walker is definitely working in the best
interests of the country part of our
mission is to find out what he's seen
and what has had him cut ties with the
CIA and his ghost brothers thank you
very much for watching and I'll catch
you in the next one
Cheers goes to do I would expect nothing
less
[Music]
you
you